okay ten fantastic designers all want to
be the new interior design master and
every week
they have to uh do up uh either a luxury
hotel
a beach hut a restaurant a salon
and then we have to eliminate people
every week
and um i know but it's so horrible
because that's
and because of covid you can't hug them
or anything because i mean
your new show i mean you can't no
they're in a bubble they
they're in a bubble we were in a bubble
but yeah well it's still tough going
isn't it
it's horrible and i say i'm afraid
you're going home and then they're
crying and then you're like
bye
[Laughter]
you might as well basically have a trap
door which leads to a skit
you know what i'm like graham i say what
i feel and i think that's what they want
but
i was surprised i was because i imagined
you'd be quite
lovely and a bit kind but you're
actually quite
harsh in the things you say really two
hours
oh no the trouble is i think because you
show up when things go wrong
that's what i hated about it because you
know what tv's like like yeah
so and so the awning's falling down and
then
we have the paint's gone over the
curtains because i'll turn up like
maleficent
so what's happened here
and then and then and then it's so funny
because
like oh at the beginning when they're
doing up the house and everything like
how are you doing oh well and you know
they're all giggly but you know there is
a time constraint they have to finish by
five o'clock and then of course i'm
turning up there 4 55
so explain how do you make this
bookshelf and then like
so yeah it was um i love doing it i love
doing it but like
you've worried me now about being too
you